[Music]
[Music]
we have returned william but we're still
in your house
well it's nice being in here dom isn't
it just lovely
well you've always you've always had
great taste in in furniture and houses
and you make your houses very
comfortable and it's lovely to be here
in your house recording the podcast uh
and being around this incredible house
plan i'm showing it for the second time
uh in in a number of weeks but it's
because we're racing around we've been
racing around like
um
like
just like racing cars racing cars like
little miniature racing cars we were
just in calgary i'm gonna be in
australia this time tomorrow you're
going to the east coast of canada then
we're meeting up in orlando to do
another convention with the boys the
hobbits and possibly
um
moving around to different parts of the
country doing the same thing so it's all
go and while we're doing all this done
we're still we're doing the friendship
onion for all of our friends and our
friends are lovely lovely people that's
true i should also just say this would
be a great opportunity here now just
very quickly just to say
thank you to everyone that was uh
reaching out to ask how uh i was because
i recently did have covered and um
it was about two and a half days of like
uh
[Music]
rubbishy head cold and that was about it
so thanks for all the well wishes and um
i hope everyone out there who is also
had or is currently having kovic is
improving
anyway hey
billy we've had some correspondence and
we should get into it because not only
do we have a ton of correspondence but
we have another fascinating guest to get
to but
hey first up
riddles in the dark someone sent us
another riddle have we got a riddle
let's do it are you doing it or am i
doing it here i'll read it
i don't know it we're only we're only
just reading this in real time here's
the riddle go we don't know who's sent
it in but
it goes like is that the riddle
yeah
no here's the riddle for you what has
four letters
sometimes has nine and never has five
what has four letters
sometimes has nine and never has five
irishi thought letters was like you know
letters from a postman instead of
letters in the alphabet i know what i
got it i've got it really is it am i
right is it less from a postman type
thing no it's not dumb is it actually
alphabetical letters
no
oh it's some other way of thinking about
the word letters is that right
or is it letters is it alphabetical
letters
is it alphabetical i mean is it dumb oh
wait i've got it
i think i've got it too
what the word what has four letters
sometimes has nine letters
and never has five letters there we go
we got it i got it slightly faster but
you got it nonetheless yeah well done
dominic nice work all right well thank
you whoever sent that in and billy you
want to read this uh
missive from brandon b well tom
i would like to
brandon b from utah says
since listening to you guys so regularly
i've noticed that
certain things you commonly say have
started to rub off on me now and i'm
starting to see them as well especially
my job as a high school earth and
environmental science teacher i'll say
things to my student like go on then
when they have an answer to a question
or that's brilliant
when they give a good answers to a good
question things like that i've never
said those phrases before so it started
me thinking says branson b from utah
what's both of you being friends so long
is there anything that either of you
commonly do that you notice has rubbed
off onto the other and now you say that
as well
well i think there's been a lot of that
over the years yeah yeah
i mean i think i'll probably say on you
go
more than i normally would based on
you and your wife quite commonly saying
on you go which is kind of a
a phrase in terms of like yeah do do it
you have my permission to do it right
yeah and a lot of people get confused
with that you remember i remember um
the the the surfer
oh kalani
kalani rob our friend kalani was it
her house and i think he wanted to go
outside for a smoke or something
and he said
can i go out here for smoke and my wife
ali said yeah on you go
and he had no idea
what she meant or what she wanted them
to do so he was like am i getting sent
home
on you go
yeah
like to me it's so natural but a lot of
people it's just like that those words
don't shouldn't be together can yeah
yeah and then you you you do a lot of
kind of fun little scenes that become
sort of habits
for
like in league of legends
you you say
just have a good time yeah just enjoy it
just enjoy just enjoy it when you get
killed and um what's the other one oh
when the game starts very often i'll
scream into the fray and i've noticed
everybody that we play with now says
those phrases yeah just enjoy it just
enjoy it
oh um
you hate to see it you know like if your
friends just got beaten up by the enemy
team you're like oh you hate to sing
you hate to see it um
i i still or at least um borrowed one
from you quite a lot which is
i think this is even back in new zealand
but you were very funny one day talking
about something that was tight tight
tight tight remember you were doing that
quite a lot you're it's tight as tight
that thing tight so now any time i
actually just say the word tight in a
sentence i'll certainly in my brain i'll
find myself going
so there we go it happens yeah i think i
think there's a lot of those things with
me and you i think yeah thanks brandon
peeling the onion
dumb yeah housekeeping oh housekeeping
do you remember the song here we go
how much fun are you
doing
[Music]
okay all right
now
do you want to read this uh question
from steve hi steve well it's actually
steve ripley here has got something um
remember we did the lauder rings riddle
which was actually quite difficult and
we had the love lovely casper rife on
who obviously knows as much about lord
of rings as anyone i've ever met and
steve ripley says
casper is correct
in the book fellowship aragorn takes
frodo to the hill of seren amroth
in lothlorien where the eleanor flowers
grow this is where in the books
aragon and irwin earlier vowed their
love for one another so when frodo finds
him here aragorn is lost in that sweet
memory
much much later after aragon dies irwin
returns to
is it karen amroth or seren amros not
sure
i'll say seren amroth and passes away
there too so irwin passes away there too
also the eleanor flowers of lithuanian
made a real impression on sam and he
names one of his daughters
eleanor
tremendous deep dive into talking law
there that was that was pretty hardcore
so casper was actually correct when we
were talking about that and a lot laurie
and the eleanor flowers do actually grow
there nice well done well done steve
ripley thanks steve well listen let's
let's answer one last question before we
bring on our fantastic guest
there's a question here from grace in
texas hi grace says i turn 22 this week
on april 20th well happy birthday um and
i was wondering if you had to pick what
would be your favorite birthday
celebration that you've ever had and
what sort of fun things did you do on
that day
oh okay
something that's actually happened or
you could make up your own i don't know
i think i assumed that that was what's
what's been a birthday that you've
enjoyed the most but it could be i guess
something in the future right um
i mean we had some nice birthdays in new
zealand right the amazing thing about us
all being in new zealand was you know
we had created our own social group with
the cast and crew so when her birthday
came along and there wasn't an
extraordinary amount to do in some of
these cities where we were filming
everyone was just like well it's billy's
birthday tonight we're all going to the
bar and it's it's kind of a built-in
party you know so we did have some
pretty humdinger parties down in new
zealand
we certainly did we did um and uh you
don't ask
a lot from people but i think you do
like people to celebrate your birthday
yeah
so we've always had uh good ones and i
have bought over the years some
wonderful wonderful gifts oh stunning
incredible yeah and don't think that's
going to change because this year i've
all i've already thought of something
for you and it's going to be a wonderful
time well billy that's great but i have
said this for a few years now and i do
subscribe to it um just this is just me
personally it's not the way that i think
about other people's birthdays but for
me personally of course as the years go
on you want to celebrate the day that
you were born that's great but it's kind
of the decades for me now i'm gonna have
a big 50th birthday i'm gonna have a big
60th i'm gonna have a big 70th hopefully
18 90 100 110 120 whatever
but the the years in between of course
nice to go out for dinner nice to see
friends but it's the big ones the big
decades now that i make a big splash
over
well do you know what then don't i just
won't give you that gift this is i'll
wait no you're absolutely right i'll
wait till you're 50 and uh i can only i
can only hope that uh
he won't pass away before that
oh that's five years ago
uh away i've ruined it oh no
need to supercharge your hiring you need
a super hiring partner you need indeed
indeed is the hiring platform where you
can attract interviewing hire all in one
place instead of spending hours on
multiple job sites searching for
candidates with the right skills indeed
a powerful hiring partner that can help
you do it all find great talent faster
through time-saving tools like indeed
instant match assessments and virtual
interviews with instant match over 80 of
employers get quality candidates whose
resume on indeed matches their job
description the moment they sponsor a
job according to indeed data us i'll
tell you what i love about indeed tom it
makes hiring all in one place very easy
because of things like instant match
candidates that you invite to apply
through instant match are three times
more likely to apply to your job than
candidates who only see it in a search
according to us indeed data
that's fantastic so start hiring now
with a 75
sponsored job credit to upgrade your job
post at indeed.com
onion all for good for a limited time
claim your own 75 credit now at
indeed.com onion
onion terms and conditions apply paper
qualified applicant not available for
all users need to hire you need indeed
really yeah the thing i love about
public goods products and they make
things like stuff to clean your sink or
to clean your floors or maybe soap and
stuff it's all kind of uniform so when
you walk into your bathroom downstairs
the bathroom upstairs has the same kind
of products it creates a nice kind of
flow in your house that's right don
public goods is a one stop shop for
sustainable high quality everyday
essentials made from clean ingredients
at an affordable price everything from
personal care and household products to
coffee
toilet paper shampoo pet food and more
public goods is the new everything store
thoughtfully designed for the conscious
consumer of which we are rather than
buying from a bunch of single product
brands public good members can buy all
of their premium essentials in one place
with one beautiful streamlined aesthetic
i love it public goods searches the
globe to find clean healthy eco-friendly
and innovative products which i
absolutely love my favorite one of
theirs is their soap i've got some like
lovely verbena lemon soap or something
oh william it's fantastic knowing what's
in your products and where they come
from is extremely important now we've
worked out an awesome deal received 15
of your first public goods order with no
minimum purchase that's right they are
so confident that you will absolutely
love their products and come back again
and again that they are giving you 15
dollars to spend on your first purchase
wow mm-hmm
you have nothing to lose just go to
publicgoods.com onion or use the code
onion at checkout that is p u b l i c g
o o d s dot com forward slash onion to
receive fifteen dollars off your first
order
well we are joined
by olympia la pointe is that how you say
your last name olympia the point or is
it like a silent t le palm ah good
question it's the point in english in
french it's le pointe but i go by
olympia la pointe olympia we're very
excited because you you have done a lot
of things that
do a lot of crossover um interests of
billy and i we're obviously both
interested in space i have what i've
always assumed is some sort of
disability with mathematics so i really
want to talk to you about that because
maybe you'll be able to uh help me or
diagnose me or cure me that would be a
fascinating thing probably all those
things dom are because olympia has
written books on it and everything
there's nothing she doesn't know about
math
and um rocket sciences well before we do
that olympia i mean very often what
billy and i do is we kind of read out a
prepared little
you know speech about what what
our fantastic guest has done with their
life but i always feel like it sounds
better coming out of the guest's own
brain so
would you be willing to just kind of
tell us
what you do and what's going on in your
world yes oh gosh
i am olympia on the pointe people know
me as an award-winning rocket scientist
i am the author of educational books
answers unleashed seen on
answersunleash.com i help people
overcome fear and embrace mathematics
and science to create the solutions for
tomorrow a lot of people have seen my
ted talk reprogramming your brain to
overcome fear and i am proud to be a
person who
has helped launch 28 nasa missions into
space and write books to help people
unleash their brains power in all the
different areas from education to
corporate worlds to
uh to our regular just everyday life so
i'm excited to be on your show today wow
absolutely perfect
that was a great intro and it makes me
very excited about talking to you and
asking some questions my first question
has to be about nasa
it would be my dream
to work at nasa doing anything
you know i mean cleaning the toilets
making tea i just made dom a cup of tea
there
so
what was your like how did you how do
you start working for nasa
do you know what it's interesting when i
was six years old i went to the jet
propulsion laboratory
and there i was there for a field trip
it was a school field trip and i saw the
rocket engines and i saw the pictures of
the men on the wall who were launching
rockets and i looked at the pictures and
i told myself i want to be just like the
men and i didn't realize how
challenging it was going to be as a
woman because typically women are not in
the rocket science world and being a
woman of color people don't know that
one out of 31 000 african-american women
or women of color
get a phd in the mathematics or
scientist science or or become a rocket
scientist and so when i was six years
old i was looking at these engines and
jet propulsion laboratories mission
control and i told myself i want to be
just like those men
but
i i
eventually went into rocket science by a
fluke
at first and this story is really
interesting i failed algebra geometry
calculus in chemistry when i was in
school
you failed all of those failed fail i
laughed now because obviously i had to
take the courses over and then i learned
to reprogram my thinking and there was a
teacher in 11th grade who helped me
understand
the the blocks that i had in my own mind
towards understanding calculus and when
i sat down with them and learned the
mathematics and science and learned the
difference between the
rate of change and uh different the
differentiation and like the
instantaneous moment i realized they
were all the same but different
vocabulary and the moment clicked in my
head where i realized
it's all how we see things and how we
name things and if we can figure out the
pattern to see the same phenomenon
happening
all we have to do is learn
the mathematics and science in
the way that someone can understand it
and so i looked at mathematics and
science as a language instead of it
looking like something that was like
crazy looking i started reprogramming my
brain to be able to see it as a language
it was communicating what was going to
happen in the future and if i could
understand what it was saying
i could be able to know what
solutions existed in the future and so i
started looking at it like that and i
eventually went to california state
university northridge where i
earned my bachelor's degree and
graduated
top of the class because i was tutoring
other people in mathematics and science
when i was
in
uh
in the campus
and afterwards when i graduated i didn't
know that i was going to go into rocket
science at all in fact
i i just wanted a job with health
insurance at first because
i had graduated and i thought to myself
i need to be able to take care of my
health and i need to have a job that has
regular health insurance and it was 1998
at the time i was 21. and i'm i'm 45 now
and i'm very thankful and proud of my
age because i've okay yes and so i'm
very proud
because it every single year is an
accomplishment to be alive and to be
here and to to go the next level and i
was 21 at the time and
um i was applying around to different
places and one of my previous
schoolmates
uh joined the boeing company
and he was working there not in the
not in the science realm per se but he
was looking at the configuration like
the drawings and making sure all the
drawings were accurate with the right
measurement
units
and making sure there was no typos on
the engineering drawings and so i asked
him well how do you like working there
and he enjoyed it so i decided to put in
an application
and when i put an application i called
up the company and i said i think you're
looking for me
nice
and they're like who are you and i'm
like olympia la pointe i think you're
looking for me
and it was probably probably a very uh
self-assured type of approach to finding
a job but they like like who are you and
i'm like i can fax you my resume take a
look
that fasted and i got the job and i
originally started in that and it was a
group of an accounting
and
i did that and i finished the work
really quickly and there was this man
down the way that understood really
advanced mathematics and science and i
was taking graduate school courses at
the time
and i asked him what he was doing and if
he could help me with my graduate school
work and i ended up having him as my
mentor and he would show me about his
engineering designs and work and
applying the mathematics and statistics
to reliability engineering and i was i
was doing what no
i'm doing what very few people do which
is volunteering my time to help them
because i was just really just naturally
curious about how do these numbers work
i've learned them all in books but let
me see how it looks in real life let me
understand
how the mathematics and the numbers
actually
uh take form what did they do how do how
do i actually solve something with these
numbers and when he showed me this i
worked with him for a year and then the
management came back to me
and said olympia we have moved you to
this next group your official title is
propulsion scientist which is
it's it's the official
name for rocket scientist and i was 21
when i started at the company and a
little bit of time after 21 maybe 22 i
was a full-fledged propulsion scientist
and that's how i got my start in rocket
science wow
and then
i was reading that at one point i think
it was during
you
working at nasa
your job was to
predict when a potentially catastrophic
event might happen in in space on a
space shuttle is that right could you
just kind of yeah extrapolate that a
little bit
oh my gosh you asked the greatest
questions and thank you for for knowing
my background of course
thank you um
i use mathematics
and science specifically statistical
probability
to calculate
the probability of a catastrophic
explosion within flight and
this show your show here i think i'm
going to tell your audience really what
that means because i really truly
believe your audience will appreciate
this
that job required
the ability for you to look at every
single duct weld joint material
structure
and figure out how the hot pressures and
gases and temperatures
were going to affect how this particular
particular engine moved
and how it would move in a way that was
designed versus a way in which would
rupture and break apart with a fire
so i use mathematics to flow the energy
through every single one of the
lines and and orifices and and manifolds
to figure out
the location that something would
explode
and if it would explode in that place
how many seconds did we have before we
could shut down
the fuel supply to that location
or how many seconds we had to be able to
give the command to mission control
to launch those astronauts off
the ship
and this is all done with math
you're not you're not going there and
looking at it and
you're basically sitting with a pen and
paper
and you can work all that out with
numbers right
yes and there's two ways to do it it's
there's what we call event sequence
diagrams where you literally have to see
what is going to happen it's like the
chain of events
you see the chain of events how they all
play into one another
and then you assign a probability to
each one of those events to know what
more than likely was going to explode
first
or
what was going to explode and be the
most catastrophic and it was all done
within pictures
and numbers and we were quite accurate
and this is from
failing math and failing your sciences
up to what up to like 10th grade
yeah i was i failed yeah the 11th grade
11th grade yeah you got to 11 that's
incredible
well that lets everybody know it's never
too late you can always turn yourself
around
true and with that in mind olympia i
mean i i
billy's known me for 20 years now and
one of the defining elements of of my
personality really
is my
inability to understand
maths or just do
simple mathematic uh sums i mean i now
know how to split a bill and or a check
and create you know work out what i
should leave for a gratuity but like
right now just in the moment right now i
don't know what seven plus four is i
have to go
eight nine eleven like i have to do that
and just to i've said billy i've told
billy this a few times and i told it to
my dad because my dad was trying to
teach me maths let's say for the sake of
argument i'm trying to add
17
to 34.
what happens is my brain
creates a picture of 17 little tiny
pieces of white chalk
and then it finds a little picture of 34
pieces of white chalk and it tries to
bring them both together and then count
how many is there so that's why when
someone asked me to do something that is
relatively simple with
maths
i find myself creating this strange
image in my brain this visual image in
which i'm having to
count them that can't be right right
yeah well do you know what is
interesting you
and
90 of the american population is the
exact same and it is similar numbers in
the uk
actually
i think it's like a
one out
actually one out of ten people
really excel in mathematics in the
united states i think it's
it's
i i
it's slightly different over uh in the
uk but this is the deal 90 of the people
in the united states have a horrible
fear of mathematics and it's like it's
like trying to like you were saying put
those numbers together in your head and
you're like this seems overwhelming how
do i keep track i mean it's just like
all these numbers how do i like how do i
do that all in my head yeah and
what i learned from failing
she's a great teacher
it is a great teacher and what i learned
from failing is not to look at the
numbers as numbers but look at them as
patterns
oh i love that sound
yeah the sound of another sale on
shopify the all-in-one commerce platform
to start run and grow your business
shopify gives entrepreneurs the
resources once reserved for big business
so the upstarts start-ups and establish
businesses alike can sell everywhere
synchronize online and in-person sales
and effortlessly stay informed
scaling your business is a journey of
endless possibility yeah it's true i
mean we've been using shopify on this
podcast and we have noticed our
merchandise shopping
growing building did you buy that
t-shirt i think i was giving this for
free but i do enjoy it and you can buy
all of our merch with shopify on our
podcast i love how shopify has the tools
and resources to make it easy for any
business to succeed from down the street
to around the globe shopify powers
millions of businesses from first sale
to full scale reach customers online and
across social networks with the
ever-growing suite of channel
integrations and apps including facebook
instagram tick tock pinterest and more
gain insights as you grow with detailed
reporting of conversion rates profit
margins and beyond more than a store
shopify grows with you this is
possibility powered by shopify go to
shopify.com
onion all lowercase for a free 14-day
trial and get full access to shopify's
entire suite of features grow your
business with shopify today go to
shopify.com onion right now shopify.com
onion
if you're like me
you're always looking to make
sustainable swaps throughout your home
maybe something that's not wrapped in
plastic or doesn't use any harmful
chemicals and hopefully doesn't involve
chopping down any trees
now luckily it seems like there are more
and more alternatives every day that i
like to use in the house and trying to
keep our earth beautiful at the same
time my new favorite sustainable swap is
real paper rio makes a sustainable
toilet paper that uses fast growing
bamboo and is always shipped in plastic
free packaging even down to the tape on
the box the great thing about bamboo is
that it's a grass and just like a lawn
it can be cut and regenerated without
harming the plant or the soil so they're
able to harvest the same plant over and
over instead of cutting down trees and
this is certainly preferable to the
usual plastic wrap toilet paper that
comes from our old growth forest the
conventional stuff contributes to
deforestation and habitat loss all for
something that we use once and then we
just flush it down the toilet well
precisely william real paper is
available in easy hassle-free
subscriptions or for one-time purchases
on their website all orders are
conveniently delivered to your door with
free shipping in 100 recyclable plastic
free packaging if you head to
realpaper.com
and sign up for a subscription using my
code onion at checkout you'll
automatically get 30 off your first
order and free shipping that's r e e l p
a p e r dot com slash onion or enter
promo code onion to get 30 of your first
order plus free shipping so let's stop
flushing our forest and give rio's tree
free paper a try zero trees zero
plastics zero compromises with real
so just like we're scared of mathematics
a lot of people are scared of the future
like
we're a lot of people are scared of
what's going to happen with artificial
intelligence they're scared about what's
going to happen within the technology
the the space travel the climate change
i mean these are like a whole lot of
things that are
in our future quantum internet hot and
if you watched the most recent news with
people being
um
people having a hologram on the
international space station from massive
shooting someone uh uh shooting a
hologram up so these are things
technology that's coming in the future
and in order to create the future that
we want we have to
not be scared of the future but actually
make effect effective decisions to
create the future that we want so we
don't create a future that we don't want
how how do you know what decisions are
right how do you
how do you know
it was that's a great question you don't
know
uh and
when
when i was launching rockets and i had
to create those pictures
of
the pathways in which the
the fuel and the the fire
and the the high pressures the pathways
that it was going to
go
that was going to launch the rocket and
not explode it
i had to create the pathway of where it
shouldn't go
right it was like
two different universes happening at the
same time
and the multiverse
both events existed
but depending on
what you did you chose the outcome that
you wanted
olympia we're getting we're getting into
court we're getting at a quantum here
aren't we this is quantum mechanics like
schrodinger's cat a little bit this is
wave forms exactly
so
these things all exist
and your decisions
chooses the universe that you then live
in
yes because exciting stuff
yes
i think so too
this is very exciting for me here
it is for me too i can talk days about
this i love days
not only days weeks hours years good
keep going this is great we're going to
sort this out i keep telling dom i
reckon i'm going to discover something
and with quantum mechanics at some point
in my life yeah he does say that but i
don't i don't know what it is yet but
we'll we might work it out right now
olympia
so i see and
when i was reading
uh about you
you also link it to spirituality
and everybody i've spoken to because
we've spoken to brian greene
about um quantum mechanics and string
theory and i've spoken to other
scientists and mathematicians but then
i've also spoken to spiritual
gurus
etc who are all saying the same thing
but neither of them
want to say
they're the same thing
so i'm kind of excited because it feels
like you might be maybe you're not i'll
let you speak for yourself but you might
be saying that the same thing
you i
i i can only explain it for what i have
witnessed and experienced and can
mathematically explain okay great
i'm a very spiritual person everyone is
different everyone has a right to
believe in whatever
they feel comfortable believing
for me i believe in god
and i believe that
science
is
the ultimate proof
that god exists and it is the extension
of
god's principles in action right and so
if i look at just the science let's say
i just just look at the science part
i realize
in my case
i had multiple futures that existed at
the same time
not a lot of people may not know my
background but i will tell
my background so the audience knows
right i grew up in severe poverty and it
was very rough growing up where i did in
south los angeles in the 1980s it was
the middle of the crack cocaine epidemic
it was where gang violence was it was
very tough growing up there
so i
had three futures in front of me i went
to that jet propulsion laboratory school
trip
where i saw these
men
in pictures launching rocket and i told
myself i wanted to be just like the men
that were launching rockets
but i also could have become a high
school dropout
and i also could have become involved or
been
a victim of gang violence because of
where i was living
i had literally this is just the three
futures that i can count and i'm
conscious of i had three futures in
front of me
equally probable
but because i chose to make a decision
at six years old to go to
the path that will allowed me to
eventually
learn and master science and i looked at
science as a way to
to always learn and grow in and learn
these new things about the universe so
you could always always learn something
new
because i chose to go that route even if
i was failing
i then
crossed out the path
of dropping out from school and being
involved in in gang violence because i
was always studying all the time always
inside
always learning
so in my case i had three futures in
front of me and it was because i chose
and made the decision using my frontal
brain lobes to go the direction of
mathematics and science
that i eventually picked the future that
was waiting for me
now albert einstein was brilliant
he said that no two people will
experience the universe the same way
because they're in two different
locations in the universe so they not
only will experience time and space
differently because of their different
locations they cannot be at the same
place at the same time
like where you're sitting right now
no one can sit in your exact time and
space except you
no one on the face of the planet because
you have
then selected that spot that you're in
at this very moment
the next five minutes no one else will
be in your position because only you can
obtain that place in time and space yep
so when you make a decision
you claim the place that you're going to
so you are the person who ends up in
that time and space and no one else is
there now this is how brilliant this
this latest book is i do and i talk
about quantum
physics
and quantum mechanics is the mathematics
that goes with quantum physics
so i created this mathematics to show
how our decisions count
we have six decisions to
navigate us to where we want to go so we
claim that spot
when we make these six decisions
we create
it's almost like a
powerful force field around us that it
and i show this mathematically that
literally attracts opportunities
and this force field
literally
is navigated by making a decision based
on your faith
how you see yourself in the world
and contributing to the world
[Music]
uh to your identity who you choose to be
how your integrity is formed and how you
choose to live out who you are
third by your
intent how you change how you plan to
impact environments and not let it
impact you
the fourth is by how you learn the
decision that you make to learn new
things and throw out that fake news
the the fifth is
how you use your resources so you
multiply it and the six is how you have
relationships with people including
yourself
not not only
in the present moment but in the past
and in the future
and when you make these six decisions
it creates this type of bond with your
future self
we each have that moment in time
where we're going to be successful in
the future every single one of us has a
moment in time and several moments in
time where we obtain what it is that
we're aiming for
when we make these six decisions
we then jump through space and time to
communicate with the future version of
ourselves so we become quantum connected
to ourself in the future so we get to
where we need to go
makes perfect perfect sense
it does i mean
i think einstein actually said didn't he
that there was no there is no
time there's no death because
you're still there you're just over
another kind of hell on the sort of
time and space
that you know so
he he didn't think it was a linear
that it's just moving he he's like oh
yeah this is just all
just this net of that you're creating
you know so it does it totally makes
sense so where do we find this book
olympia oh gosh you can go to my website
answersunleast.com
and underneath books you'll see the
the science of attraction and that is
underneath answers unleash
dot com slash book three
you can see and pick up uh the
you can actually download
the latest version of my book you can
download it from any place in the world
and i'm excited because
my first book mathophobia deals with how
people can embrace science and
mathematics and actually
really learn it and my latest book
answers unleash to the science of
attracting what you want
deals with how you make decisions so you
can jump to the future that you choose
and then come back and make the six
decisions to get there
and i'm absolutely sure that that is
true and actually dom
is probably
the greatest person i've ever known at
doing that sort of stuff
he
he's
incredibly strong in his mind probably
what you're talking about the frontal
lobes
that he'll make a decision i've seen him
do it
through our long friendship now
that he'll say
like a silly thing one time we were
sitting on the floor and he said i'm
going to work out how you pick yourself
up off the floor turn around and get me
a handstand i was like you'll never be
able to do that and within a few months
he'd done it
and like with the with the
the wild things the show that he was
telling you about
he
he felt passionate about
i want people to start liking these
insects and spiders and snakes and
all nature shows are always
either you know the big animals or the
cute animals and he wanted to do this
show and he sort of
probably
the way that you're talking about but
without him knowing it sort of made that
happen you know
saw himself in that future yeah i never
really i never really connected too
strongly to
manifestation or what i was doing until
people started to point out to me like
oh you seem to be quite
um
well versed at manifestation and i was
like what does that mean that just
sounds like a kind of la kind of cool
and groovy hippie speed thing
and then people you know like billy
would be like well you said this and
then 18 months later you did it or you
said this and then you put the wheels
into motion to do it and it's funny
because like if i look back on certainly
some of the more benchmark moments in my
in my life and in my career you know
when i was
i think between the ages of
13 and 15 i had
an iconic poster of lord of the rings in
my bedroom and i would look at it every
all the time multiple times a day and i
would think if they make a film of lord
of the rings that has to be the number
one
thing that i would want to do because at
that point i always wanted to wanted to
be
an actor obviously that turned into
doing rings and then i wanted to live in
hawaii that's another thing that
happened i just wanted to live in hawaii
i was like hawaii they surf the food
there's chameleons that live there wild
it's out in the middle of the pacific
it's kind of a you know one of the most
isolated archipelagos of islands on the
planet and i was like i just want to
live in hawaii somehow i want to work
that out
i got a job that had me moved to hawaii
for like you know three plus years and
um
it just
to your point olivia it's like
the more you do something the more you
find positive affirmations in things
that you are doing and this and the
success quote-unquote in achieving those
things the more your brain is inclined
to do it in the same way that in a
reverse fashion i had been telling
someone at this convention or all
weekend that he needed to stop saying
the word hate and he kind of looked at
me kind of laughing and i was like nah
man you should not be bringing that
world that word into your existence it
shouldn't be moving through your system
it's not good for you it's just a
negative thing say something like i find
this really challenging or this is
something that i'm struggling with or
this is something that i'm trying to get
better with but don't say i hate this
and i hate that because it gives power
to that thing that has too much control
over you you know does that sound about
right
manifesting
what you're saying is true we have the
ability to manifest things and i'm going
to take it a step farther and i'm going
to take it a step that is really
concrete
we bring about the future that we want
and we manifest it based on our
decisions
the decision that we make on a daily
basis is what is what allows our
tomorrow to be the way it is
like for example if someone is let's say
someone is like a a person
to save every single day and spend time
and create that computer software look
look at the like the founders of
facebook and amazon and like
all these other things they spent years
years inside
dedicating their life to these computer
algorithms
that eventually paid them billions
so
it's like that decision making process
of what are you going to do today that's
going to invest in tomorrow
so
like when i was younger
i saw myself like the men in the
pictures but when my 30s before i wrote
my book i would often go to bookstores
and i would pick up the books
and i would bring my own picture and i'd
put it on the other books and i'd look
at the book as if it were my book
and so i literally put a picture of
myself and then put the name of my book
before it was mathophobia i created my
fictitious
book cover before i even wrote the book
and i put it on the wall and i kept
looking at the cover of the book it took
me three years to write my first book
and i kept looking at that book cover
every single day and it was my own
fictitious book cover that i created but
it reminded me i'm going to do this and
i'm going to write this book and it was
like
it was it was the thing that changed my
life and it led me to my ted talk and it
led me to create my book series and my
answers only platform but not only that
i i learned that
when we start
programming
our mind
to where we're going to go
we then start making decisions that will
map up to that future like for myself
now i used to
teach as a math professor
for i was in rocket science for 10 years
i left and then i started my company and
then
at three years after that i created my
first book but i was really doing my
best at the time and i started part-time
teaching as a mathematics professor
teaching students and as i was telling
my students about all these theories
about how their brain works and like oh
look at it like this or when you look at
it like this it helps your brain do that
and they're like professor lapointe you
need to write a book about this and my
students were the ones that suggested
that future and i'm like maybe i can and
then i started putting up the book
picture on the wall going to my local
bookstore just walking to my local
bookstore
probably like every day just checking
out the different books and finding out
how they did their contents of it and
that led me to create my book publishing
company where i create books
but
that same type of process of
manifestation can be applied at any
point in our any point in our lives any
point
for me now i see myself being it this
isn't necessarily happening yet but i
see myself as a person behind a desk
a broadcast to millions of people where
i'm describing science in a way that's
really clear for everyone to understand
and millions of people are tuning in on
a regular basis to see whatever it is
i'm presenting at this desk and it is
helping people understand the truth of
how their brain works and how they learn
and how information comes with science
olympia we could talk to you all day
this has been a fascinating conversation
like truly i thought that maybe we were
going to touch upon
one or two things but everything that
you talked about i'm i'm like oh i have
25 more questions for you but um
unfortunately we don't have any more
time we'd love to have you come back and
maybe we can we can do a more of a
deeper dive into
space or into quantum or into
mathematics and in the meantime i'll try
and improve on my um
on my relationship with numbers thank
you very much that was really wonderful
and we'd love to have you back on we'll
we'll read your latest book and uh maybe
you could come on and tell us some more
it will be my honor to be on your show
again thank you so much
well dom what a fantastic chat with an
incredibly interesting olympia le point
well billy remember a few episodes back
we had uh an entomologist gentleman on
that was talking to us about insects and
i said i would love to be trapped with
you on a long-haul flight when olympia
was talking it made me think god i bet
billy wishes he could be trapped in a
room with her for 12 hours to talk about
quantum law and talk about spacecrafts
and nasa and mathematics she was a very
fascinating person we'll have to have a
back
so interesting yeah i wanted to get we
ran out of time obviously but i mean
just that
that sort of idea of
that i think came from um
uh
einstein that time isn't really a sort
of linear thing then like so as
all these different future doll mona
hands all over and it's your decisions
that slots you into one or slots you
only another and it's really really
interesting brilliant stuff and yeah
let's see let's let's um
get an opportunity at some point to
bring it back and maybe we do a deeper
dive into one specific element as
opposed to an overview of what she does
because there's just so much to talk
about with olympia and i would recommend
people go listen to our ted talk and get
those books if you if you found that
interesting those books from her website
will put her website information in the
show notes guys remember if you have a
tongue twister if you have a riddle if
you have a food item that you want us to
eat on billy and dominate the world get
in touch with us you guys dictate what
we're gonna do with the show you can
leave questions comments and concerns on
our youtube channel we would love it if
you would rate review and especially
subscribe to the show because the more
subscribers we get the more we can
continue to make the show and don't
forget if you want to look incredibly
cool get some friendship onion
merchandise at the
friendshiponionpodcast.com
yeah and we'll see you guys next week
see you next week
[Music]
harmonize with me and hold me back all
through the night you're shining bright
i'm your host the baby you're my
[Music]